first time since cole irvin is facing
these angels that it will be a
successful day for him and if you look
back on the starts that we're talking
about
he had a 4-1 lead against the minnesota
twins when he left that game and
unfortunately twins came back and wanted
so cole irvin needs to do exactly what
he's done in the early part of the
season just use both sides of the plate
fastballed in the changeups away
so one and two the count to phil gosling
one two pitch swing and a miss good
change up by cole urban and that's how
the ball game starts
there's that change up on display we saw
a little bit of a different changeup
earlier in the count but this one here
with depth gonna be a strike as is
first pitch to shohei ohtani out to the
right side olson has it
and he throws it past irvin and ohtani's
going to be aboard
two out that'll bring up juan logaris
who's batting at 250.
accuse that one toward olsen he grabs it
steps on the bag
so the air does not hurt the ace jose
quintana
well this is a difference right last
three starts have gotten a little bit
better unfortunately for jose that
season era of 792 is the highest era
among starting pitchers
in big league baseball he'll tell you
i'm much better than that suzuki took a
while to sell him on a pitch
but he sold him on a fastball inside
corner down goes cannon
chapman who's been moved up to the two
hole will be the next batter
here's the next delivery and that one
there brings him down to his knees
chasing that curveball
the 01 pitch it's on the way and jet
hits the drive to left field deep
gosselin going back
he will turn and watch and it's off the
very top of the wall
in play lowry goes to second with a
slide with a double
so that's good at bat by olsen as he
lays off
pitch that drop low so two out rally for
the eights the 2-2 fish to chance swung
a lifted right side a long run into foul
territory
and the right fielder makes the catch
and a good running catch
by taylor ward crossing the foul line
and the first batter up for the angels
will be jared walsh
he's 10th and runs bad at it hammers
that one through the zone and drives it
up over and out of here jared walsh with
his 12th home run of the year
and the angels strike first that's that
day game carry there
in oakland off the bat you're thinking
okay that's got a good chance to get
down one hop the wall but just kept
carrying
it's over to 387 third home run versus a
lefty this year
kurt suzuki's on here hits the start off
the inning taylor ward will be the next
batter
ninth pitch and this at bat is served
into left field for a base hit
home run walsh single suzuki single
ward the runners move up suzuki to third
ward to second
[Applause]
fletch lines that one into left field it
is down
over to play it is pender a pair of
angels will score
the most clutch of all halo hitters gets
it done again
david fletcher it's three to nothing
this catches a lot of the plate david
fletcher turns on it
flips it down into left field angels
score a couple fletcher able to get
to second base here's gosselin the lead
off man
the goose is loose down the right field
line
here comes fletch to score oh goose
spread your wings and fly
the goose coming through going the other
way
on a two-strike pitch fletch
scoring the fourth run of the inning the
a's trying to continue a comeback
they're down four nothing
against quintana rounds this one
toward fletcher fletcher and the hole
throws on the run and he throws wide
cannon and that opens the door for matt
chapman as he stands in with kenna board
at first base
in the dirt and it's a walk so an air
and a walk
and these have something rolling here in
the third
and the 3-2 inside he
takes ball forward that was close and
now with the bases loaded and nobody out
here's the tying run suddenly
and the person to matt olson 3-2 pitch
is not close olson takes it
trotting in the scores canada and the
a's are on the board so here's pinder
with the bases loaded
into the catcher's minute goes chased an
elevated fastball
a huge first out of the inning not out
of it yet
base is still loaded one run in a's down
four to one and one out and here's
murphy
reach for poke toward right ward has it
chapman tags chapman to the plate he
will score it's a sacrifice five for
murphy to make it four to two
so here is moreland he is the seventh
batter in the inning runners at first
and third two outs
and he did well a lot to deal with an
error
three walk sac fly four to two
now this is a a strong statement here
jose suarez takes to rock and he rolls
jose quintana
removed from this game you can see what
he's done in the big leagues had the
same numbers in
aaa this year as well here's the pitch
this is
chopped right to short fielded there by
fletcher and he will easily throw out
biscotti
takes a pitch away changeup drives it
the other way but it's run down by ward
as he closes the gap
and then lower our mango big tough
breaking ball
fastball outside corner yeah they may
have knocked him around a couple of
years ago but he has returned to the big
leagues ready to go to work
jose suarez back out for his second
inning of work
there's that change up again it's lifted
to left
it's shy of the track
oh he got him with the breaking ball
good adjustment in getting a swing and
miss
with a breakable lowry's got an edge to
him today yes he does yes
olson the count jumps to owen two oh
baby three change-ups in a row
they could not get olsen to swing and
miss to save their life early in the
game
run away so here is david fletcher
one for two day with a two-run double
rojas waiting on deck fletch takes a
shot down that first base line there he
goes again
picking him up putting him down heading
into second fletch
with the slide it's a double for david
fletcher
fifth two bagger sixth including the one
earlier today of the year
mr contact has been a long time since
the swing and miss and he puts this in
play
three balls no strikes here's the next
pitch
and he missed inside so
a four pitch walk and shohei will
head to first base and rendon will have
a chance to do something here with two
outs and two runners on
he awaits the pitch and here it is it's
fly to center and that'll end the inning
kenna has a read on it stays with him
mark fighting the sun makes the grab
so now walsh at first lagarus at second
angels batting in the eighth this one's
popped up
and olson's gonna have a play coming
down the line
so suzuki is retired one away is looking
for two on taylor ward
here's the pitch by bedrosian swung on
driven to left center
cannaback has a play on it makes the
catch tagging is legaures but he's not
going to try to advance
canada plays it back it was a well hit
ball but well read
by kenneth there's kian wong in his
second major league game
since september of 2019.
swinging a miss on a high fastball long
strikes out
and the angels strand a pair so here's
rysel iglesias
he comes in with two outs here in the
eighth inning
and pinder at second base iglesias with
the next pitch
and that is a called third strike he
froze him right there
on a changeup and that is how the inning
will
end we'll head to the bottom of the
ninth we'll see if the angels can hold
on
one go on in the bottom of the ninth
it'll be seth brown stepping up
changeup got him wow and two out
and that'll bring up canna oh one pitch
swings at this one and lifts this ball
in the air in the left center and making
a nice running catch out there is
jose rojas to put it away and the ball
game
is over